[Music]
foreign so let's get cracking with the
Press preview shall we it's a first look
at what is on the front pages and
tonight we'll check out the headlines
with the political editor of HuffPost UK
Kevin Schofield our former Barrister and
former government Minister and a Subaru
great to see you both we shall chat in a
moment after we've had a look at those
front pages for you well after the
shotgun cartridge security alerts at
Buckingham Palace the Metro reports that
a ring of Steel has been thrown around
King Charles for Saturday's coronation
according to the front of the mail it's
the biggest Security operation ever
well the mirror says police have won
there's to be swift action against any
anti-monarchy demonstrations that turn
to criminality
while the eye looks beyond the
coronation and says the plan is for the
king to help mend the UK's toxic
relationship with the rest of Europe
after brexit
the express reports that scientists are
on the brink of a new drug treatment for
Alzheimer's disease which could help
millions of sufferers and in fact it's
the same lead story for tomorrow's Daily
Telegraph as you can see there well the
guardian claims an exclusive with a
report on the extent of historic links
between the slave trade and some of
Britain's top schools
and the star picks up on growing fears
about the effect on us all of artificial
intelligence with the headline he's not
the Messiah he's a very naughty chatbot
is the Ft reporting that the head of the
London Stock Exchange wants higher pay
for UK company bosses to stop them
moving overseas
and the sun tells us that singer Taylor
Swift has a new boyfriend the front man
of the band The 1975 Matty Healy
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and to discuss them
Kevin Schofield and Anna subri lots to
talk about uh this evening
um Anna why don't we kick off with you
front page of the eye talking about the
coronation but more in the context of
what's going to happen afterwards and
their headline uh that Charles III plans
to help lead brexit detox with Europe
but we know that he chose his first uh
State visit to be in Germany didn't he
he was going to go to Bordeaux in France
that had to get canceled but there is a
plan I think to perhaps send in there
later on in the year
yes I think this is actually really
quite interesting because we know that
the trip to Germany was hugely
successful uh and it I mean yeah he was
as you say he was meant to go into
France but because of all the protests
against macron's Plans over pensions
they just couldn't have that visit so he
went to Germany it was very successful
what the eye is saying is that after the
correlation he's going to help repair
our damaged relations primarily with
France and go with sulac the prime
minister to sort of smooth the waters
and and do a better job with working
with France and the other member states
of the European Union and whatever you
have used on brexit 911 widely known
that must be a good thing
um and you know as I say whatever your
views on brexit we have to work much
much better with those people right on
our doorstep especially when it comes to
trade so perhaps we're going to be
seeing the beginning of a more sensible
relation with the European Union and who
knows where that might lead to yeah but
Anna does it does it not ring any alarm
bells that the the Monarch getting a
little political
no no I mean it is it it is absolutely
the role of the Monarch when there are
important
um
relationships to either create or to
encourage or to grow or if they're
damaged to repair and the monarchy has
let me know working closely with France
I mean anybody who has a problem with
that frankly has a huge problem anyway
uh but but this is this is this must be
right and I don't think it's overly
political at all it makes a lot of sense
Kevin
yeah I think as long as it's done
properly then I think it should be okay
I mean obviously we know that the way
our system works is that the Monarch is
the head of state but tries to rise
above
politics but at the same time the royal
family is an important soft power tool
for uh the UK and yeah as Anna says the
visit to State visit to Germany
um surpassed all expectations I think it
was incredibly successful and I think
maybe Richie sunick has spotted that and
sees an opportunity now to to use Prince
Chuck Prince Charles I keep saying
Prince Charles to um to use King Charles
as that
um that way of rebuilding British
because there's no doubt that in the
wake of of brexit um relationships with
with European capitals has been hugely
damaged
um over the last several years and
anything that can be done to to patch
that up I think has to be a good thing
okay well let's stay uh with the King
but talk about more pressing matters the
countdown to the coronation two days to
go the Metro Ring Of Steel thrown uh
around Charles um a bit worrying Anna
wasn't it this uh this incident
yesterday evening and and according to
the Metro so um they're saying that the
plan has been reviewed after that man
was arrested outside the front of the
palace
yeah it makes a lot of sense though
because what you don't want is somebody
who and apparently the man that was
responsible for this had mental health
problems that you you don't want that
one person who may or may not have
mental health problems but getting
through who might be a an actual threat
either to the king or to somebody else
in this great state occasion but with of
course so many other heads uh and very
senior members of other states there as
well so it makes a huge amount of sense
to revisit it to make sure that what
will be a hugely happy occasion is in no
way spoiled but I mean I think some of
this is a bit over the top but I and you
know the idea that that there's going to
be some clamp down on protesters and so
on and so forth I mean I think that's a
lot of puff and it was a bit
disappointing to hear the government
Minister going out talking about it I I
think that which is a different matter
to a security threat
um but but that's just been overpuff to
to sort of cause trouble when there is
no trouble
a beautiful picture on the front of
tomorrow's mail
um of the the gold State coach that uh
uh early morning uh rehearsal taking
place Uh Kevin that mail have gone for
biggest Security operation ever as well
um I mean the police are saying that
they're welcoming these new laws which
will let them really clamp down on any
disruptive protests and what have you
made about those comments today
yeah I mean I think they have to use
those Powers carefully though I mean I I
don't think the message we want to send
around the world is that we clamp down
on protest I think we have a pretty
proud tradition in this country of being
able to to demonstrate and robust uh
debate about matter such as this now you
can argue whether it's the time of the
place to be mounting protests some would
argue it's the perfect time to be
um protesting about uh the monarchy that
being said you know I think they'll very
much be in the minority on among the
crowds that are there but I mean as long
as it's done peacefully then I don't see
a problem with it myself and as I say I
don't think the police will want to be
too heavy-handed because the eyes of the
world will be on London on Saturday and
you know it's important that we send out
the right message and hopefully it All
Passes off without any incident
um Kevin let's stay with you um for a
changing story uh talking about that um
rather bizarre incident uh over the
Kremlin uh just looking at the telegraph
Russian Hawks demand brutal Revenge
after drone hits Kremlin what what did
you make of this story
yeah it is quite bizarre I mean these
are unverified uh reports from Russia of
a drone attack on the Kremlin um
explosions above the Kremlin
um now Russia are insisting that this
was a terrorist attack by Ukraine an
attempt to assassinate Vladimir Putin
which if true would be an incredible
development real I mean this this is one
of the most
um
heavily protected men on the planet so
if this was if this was genuinely what
is what happened then you have to read
serious questions I think about Russian
security systems however you know a lot
of people are taking what Moscow has
seen with a heavy pinch of salt and
unsurprisingly now it's been used as a
pretext to
um to up the ante effectively as far as
the invasion of Ukraine is concerned
that the Hawks our own Vladimir Putin
are saying that they have to go in even
harder now as our retaliation now uh
Vladimir zielinsky is in Finland at the
moment and he said categorically that
um Ukraine had nothing at all to do with
this that the fighting they're doing is
on their own land against the Russian
Invaders and they've got no interest in
taking the war to Russia now Western
officials have said it as I said it's
unverified so they've not been able to
say one way or another but as I say I
think I would be pretty skeptical
um about what Russia sees happens
because as I say this has now been used
as a pretty clear pretext to um to
intensify the bombardment of Ukraine
yeah the Kremlin saying it's an
assassination attempt and as you say
zelenski saying we don't attack Putin or
Moscow we fight on our territory
um but Anna as Kevin was saying there um
it could be an excuse couldn't it to not
only up the rhetoric but up attacks on
Ukraine and potentially Kev
yeah that that is the real fear isn't it
that it is just a false flag it is just
being done as an excuse to do exactly
that
um I mean it I mean it looks like some
sort of large firework with the idea
that that's to assassinate anybody is is
just ludicrous but excuse me
it is more the rhetoric around it that
is concerning
um and and and right we are right to be
concerned about that because as we know
this war has not been the success that
um Putin thought it was going to be uh a
drag song which is terrible from Ukraine
people but it it is also bad for those
people in Russia whose sons are being
killed in the way that they are being
killed out there but it drags on
um and you would have thought that Putin
would would want to amp everything up
because he's he's failed miserably he
said it was going to be all over in days
uh yeah our um correspondent in Moscow
uh saying it's quite surreal this attack
happening at just days before they
commemorate Victory Day uh in Russia
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Kevin and Anna are still with us
front pages of Daily Telegraph Anna we
need some good news don't we we
desperately need some good news and the
telegraph uh front of the express I
think as well have supplied it best ever
Alzheimer's drug can halt uh disease
this was this this was a very
encouraging news wasn't it British
scientists saying that the trial of this
new drug is hugely exciting and the
Alzheimer's Society even saying it
signals the beginning of the end of
Alzheimer's um there have been a few
breakthroughs we have to be careful
about using that web breaker Anna don't
we but there have been a few
breakthroughs when it comes to
alzheimer's recently
yeah and and I mean obviously the
reaction is gosh I hope you're right I
hope it is the beginning of the end
because
it is we we are we're all familiar with
what a horrible terrible disease it is
an absolutely steals a person with long
before they actually pass away and this
drug they are saying that they're a
number of years before is going to get
onto into into the NHS and so on but as
you rightly say this is yet another uh
drug or a treatment which is giving real
hope to people that this is going to now
be something that we can properly tackle
and you know it all comes down to
research and that and that actually
comes down to money and you know you
look at what David Cameron tried to do
whatever your views on David Cameron
back in 2010 he was adamant he was going
to set up
um some really good serious money into
research and when we put the money into
research whether it's through taxpayers
or whether it's through the generosity
of Ordinary People and we put it into
whether it's cancer or as with something
with Alzheimer's which was which was
always a I think a lot of us thought bit
of a Cinderella disease didn't quite get
the sort of
um sympathy if you like from a giving
point of view into that research but my
goodness me it pays off and we're
beginning to see that now so let's hope
it is this big breakthrough and it's the
beginning of the end of it well let's
hope so uh Kevin as Anna says that it's
some way off
um becoming available and and that's
because the trials haven't been without
upset to volunteers possibly a third
died after dangerous swelling to the
brain who took part in this the company
saying like many effective treatments
for debilitating and fatal diseases
there are associated risks that may be
serious and life threatening
um so there's some way to go but
nonetheless it would be fantastic
wouldn't it to to be rid of this awful
disease
what would be an absolutely incredible
breakthrough
um I start with to be the case I mean
not least because obviously we have an
aging population
therefore more people and more of us are
likely to unfortunately be affected or
afflicted by this disease so you know
anything that
um raises hopes of a successful
treatment or a way of at least
slowing down the process would be a
phenomenal breakthrough and hopefully no
help um even ease the pressure on the
National Health Service as well
um that is obviously caused by by this
disease so so yeah fingers crossed but
as you say you know we're not there yet
more research has to take place more
tests have to be carried out but thus
far anyway it looks certainly from these
initial results it's um extremely
extremely promising and hopefully it
will it will continue yeah fingers
crossed um and Anna let's finish very
quickly with this on the front of the Ft
I mean this is this is going to uh um
upset people who are struggling to feed
themselves isn't it Executives should be
paid even more
I I know this is from the boss of the
London Stock Exchange uh Julia hoggatt
who's making the point that I mean she's
looking at the market and and look when
I say there's an analogy with say junior
doctors obviously not in terms of pay I
mean apparently the average Chief
Executives pay now is
3.9 million pounds a year and obviously
people are going to say what and and the
chief executive of the London Stock
Exchange says we're gonna have to pay
people more I think the point she's
trying to to make is that there is a
market and that's exactly what the
junior doctors are saying they're saying
yeah there is a market and we could be
paid an awful lot more if we go to
Australia and if you want to recruit and
retain you're going to have to pay us
more and I know in my profession at the
bar where in exactly the same we don't
have enough but this front page of the
ft and this claims that extremely
well-paid people should be paid even
more is he's not going to
Kevin we've only got about 15 seconds
for one quick thought
yeah I mean I'm fair play to the first
politician that was into an election
saying that they will raise a
for chief Executives so unfortunately I
can see why she's saying it but I don't
think this one that is going to fly
unfortunately far